So it started when I was looking for
someone to help me with a marketing task
and I searched for someone on Elance and
he said, hey I can do it.
Said okay let's do it and
we started talking,
we had our first our discovery meeting.
Scary phone call and he said,
you know what by the way I
also have another R&D company.
And I said, really?
Yeah, we have like ten people here.
And I told him, I'm looking for
an R&D company,
do you think you can do this project?
And I was just working on my first
project working with a similar web and
he said yeah.
And since then we
started working together
in almost everything that they did.
He became a part of the company,
a real part of the company and
we became partners.
Because he understood what I need,
I understood what he needs,
we wanted to help each other.
And in our relationship became so solid
that eventually I came to visit him and
to visit his employees because they
wanted to personally know the people
who are working for us on the project.
I wanted them to know that I care.
I do care, one of them just
invited me to his wedding.
And they are really great people, and
I wanted to know them more in person
because they're just like employees
they just happen to live far, far away.
And and that I was there for
36 hours but that really changed
everything for us because
all the sudden it's a real person,
it's not an email, so it's not a Skype.
It's not someone on Slack.
It's a real person that you're going and
having fun with went all for drinks and
dinner and play ball and
all of a sudden we're
part of the siame group that actually
meet not also only work remotely